this is another Fox News Alert breaking
news about u.s. immigration policy how
the president intends to enforce it and
how migrants from Central America are
trying to get around it
we have Fox team coverage on this
breaking news william la jeunesse in
Tijuana Mexico where migrants have
flooded the border town angering many
who live there new details about that
Caravan - but we start off with national
security correspondent Jennifer Griffin
at the Pentagon with some confusion this
afternoon about troop levels along the
border could even Jennifer good evening
Bret in an interview with Politico
Lieutenant General Jeffrey Buchanan the
Army General overseeing the deployment
of 5,800 US troops to the border said
some of those troops could start coming
home this week and that all of the
troops will likely be home by Christmas
even as a caravan of migrants continues
to make its way to Tijuana u.s. customs
officers were forced to close a border
crossing near Tijuana as a result
Lieutenant General Buchanan also
confirmed reports that Fox News and
others have reported that the Pentagon
pushed back on a request by DHS for
armed u.s. troops to be in contact with
migrants citing a lack of legal
authority general Buchanan said today
some of the engineering troops are no
longer needed because their job is done
so some may be able to start leaving
this week quote our end date right now
is December 15th and I've got no
indications from anybody that will go
beyond that Buchanan told POLITICO
however some of the troops sent to Texas
could be sent to help in other spots
along the border if need be according to
to those familiar with the planning
bread okay Jennifer Griffin with the
details from the Pentagon tonight
Jennifer thank you